Are you in
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie The Flash
released a new promo there's a whole bunch of new
footage so we'll break it all down so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos James Gunn will be announcing with
all the new DC movies are going to be in his DC
Phase One reboot of all the movies with different
actors playing all the characters really soon we
won't have to wait that long to find out what
the first batch of his movies are going to be
one of the few ones that he has already announced
is the new version of the Superman movie that he's
creating with the younger Superman of course I
will do videos for all that stuff whatever he
winds up announcing it's only the biggest thing
that's happened in comic book movies since they
recast Andrew Garfield as The Amazing Spider-Man
getting rid of Tobey Maguire temporarily and then
a few years later recast again with Tom Holland
only to bring Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire
back in Spider-Man no way home so all this
nonsense going on at DC movies should feel
of Barry Allen flash from his show they actually
featured him on the DCTV version of the crisis on
infinite Earth hopefully he has a cameo somewhere
in the movie in the background you see the main
Allen time travels to the pass to save his mother
from the reverse flash just like Flashpoint in
the comics except in doing so completely changes
the timeline causing Butterfly Effects destroying
his future effectively his present day they did a
version of it during the flash season 1 Season 2
Season 3. that's where all the older Grant Gustin
flash memes came from sure is a nice timeline be a
real shame if someone messed it up if they hadn't
put two versions of Batman and Supergirl in this
movie that would have been a solid movie poster
for this the newer Grant Gustin flash memes over
Oliver Queen's grave are the ones that everyone's
gonna remember though because they're more recent
that he finds another version of himself like
another Barry Allen who looks just a little bit
different like you can tell that his haircut is
a little bit different the outfit that he wears
is a little bit different he's wearing this yellow
jacket you see him in the trailer looking at the
that the main Barry Allen has he doesn't have the
same flash suits he hasn't experienced the events
of Justice League he doesn't know the same group
of characters that are main Barry Allen knew but
it does seem like he also lost his mother as a
boy so they do share the same tragedy of their
childhood while Maine Barry Allen is trying
to figure out what he did wrong to change the
timeline with the help of Michael Keaton's Batman
who seems really annoyed by him like look you can
obviously but Barry Allen is a forensic scientist
he's supposed to be very smart but he works at
Central City Police Department he's not like the
level of engineer that he'd have to be in order
to create a duplicate of his own new upgraded
flash suit and Flash ring you probably saw the
Ben Affleck's Batman was supposed to be in the
movie he's the one who gives the main Barry Allen
The Flash ring in the new Flash suit they did it
in a tie-in comic that they released before the
movie came out I believe you can actually go read
it right now he keeps the new Flash suit inside
the flash ring it's meant to be just like the
comics and speaking of reboot's characters not
coming back originally I think had Ray Fisher not
had all the problems that he did with the studio
they would have said that cyborg used his mother
box hyper technology to create the flash ring in
the new suit with Batman's help originally he
was a much bigger part of the plot have been
all kinds of talks about him being a pretty big
character in the movie but then he had all those
problems so they rewrote the movie and he wasn't
in it anymore when Maine Barry Allen is teaching
this other Barry Allen about the speed force
about being the flash they create a secondhand
suit using other parts that they can find because
they're in Michael Keaton Batman's bat cave the
other parts are essentially one of his spare
Batman suits so this other flash is wearing a
repainted Batman suit you can see the chest plate
lines here and that's why the neck piece on his
suit looks so weird it's super thick like Batman's
cow because it is literally Batman's cow with the
just make reverse flash the main villain of the
movie they do have a version of Michael Shannon
Zod and feora coming back as Multiverse versions
of their characters who didn't die at the hands
her her in this prison and recognize who she is
learning her relationship to his Superman from his
Earth I'm not sure what they're gonna say happened
to him in this alternate universe either his pod
never crashed on this Earth or it hasn't reached
it yet or he was killed at some point Henry Cavill
did film a cameo scene as his main version of
Superman I'll explain that in a second the other
villain of the movie and arguably I think the
main villain of the movie is actually dark flash
different actor or using reverse flash he's meant
to be a version of Barry Allen who didn't learn
the same lesson that he learned a Flashpoint why
you're not supposed to change the past he goes off
getting in trouble with the law it's the evil
Barry Allen who's taken over but I think the idea
is that by the end of the movie the main conflict
will be regular Barry Allen versus the dark flash
obviously they have changed a couple things about
the movie because of James Gunn's big reboot of DC
movies originally they were going to use the movie
to set up a bunch of future crisis on infinite
Earth stuff in the movies I believe that's what
Henry cavill's Superman Cameo was going to do he
was supposed to show up towards the end of the
movie Inside the speed force teasing some future
crisis like big Multiverse conflict and it would
have been them doing a movie version of what you
saw in the TV shows they did a much bigger version
of that on DC TV I believe the movie version would
have just been like an even more expensive
even bigger version with more versions of the
characters from previous movies like oh this is
how they're going to bring George Clooney's Batman
and Robin bag all those classic Justice League
actors just rubbing their hands like oh can't wait
to come back James Gunn's plans for the next 10
years of DC are meant to be completely different
he might also do a version of crisis on infinite
Earths but it's meant to be a very different plan
from what the studio had back in October because
that's why Henry Cavill said that the studio told
him to tell everyone in the world that he was back
as Superman in October over after Black Adam came
out because at the time the studio wanted him to
come back and do a version of Man of Steel 2 and
be a big part of this future crisis on infinite
Earth but then just a little while later by
November James Gunn was hired and had completely
different plans it's like you know what no we're
not going to do Henry Cavill Superman we're going
to do a younger version we're going to recast all
to come out at the end of 2023 Ben Affleck's
Batman also filmed a cameo scene for that I don't
know if that got taken out as well they haven't
said anything about Grant Gustin having a cameo
scene in the movie but it would be weird for him
to not have a cameo scene in the film they filmed
it last year so I think there would have been
time for him to film some sort of walk-on Cameo
even if it was a brief moment the flash season
9 is meant to be the last season of the show
so it feels like they would try to wrap all those
hanging plot threads up but the whole idea during
the DC TV version of crisis on infinite Earth is
that they canonize the arrowverse to the larger
scene here was that his flash didn't know that he
was called The Flash yet because in the movies up
to that point they hadn't called him the flash
yet they just kept calling him Barry flash flash
so when they meet in Grant Gustin says I'm the
flash Ezra Miller kind of Ponders It For a Moment
Like The Flash wow that actually sounds like a
pretty cool name just because he's hearing it
for the first time when he disappears at the end
obviously it's because of what's happening with
the DC TV version of crisis on infinite Earth but
I'm wondering if they actually end the movie now
with a way that'll actually explain that in a new
context like oh it's because of this big reboot
that's happening is because of what Ezra Miller's
Barry Allen does during The Flash movie like just
blame all of the flashes on what's happening with
the reboot just blame it on their version of new
Flashpoint then maybe if they do some Multiverse
stuff way down the road like five ten years plus
they'll bring some of those other actors back and
do more of a legit version of crisis on infinite
Earths but let me know in the comments if they
are rebooting all of DC movies let me know in
the comments how you want them to wrap up each of
the movies that are happening this year if they're
still a part of the Snyder versus DC movies
and everybody's not coming back after that it
just feels like if they leave a little bit of an
explainer at the end of The Flash movie with a
flash point and just say that this is happening in
an alternate universe it makes way more sense when
the new version of the actors show up like oh this
is just another universe that we're looking at the
other big news is that they are going to release
another Flash trailer at the Super Bowl they'll
probably be a couple other really big trailers
of course they'll do videos for all that stuff
whatever they wind up releasing make sure you
enable alerts from my channel so you don't miss
that there'll be some more Shazam Fury the gods
trailers really soon too because that'll be like
the first big DC movie of the year we also have a
brand new Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania trailer
that's coming next week of course I'll do a video
for that as well everyone click here for that and
click here to learn about Ben Affleck coming
back to play a new Marvel character in Marvel
phase five thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!